LORIN PRICE: My
name is Lorin Price,
and I'm a Networking
Specialist Customer
Engineer at Google Cloud.
And today, I'm going to talk
to you about the networking
concepts for Cloud Run
that are helpful to know
for implementation,
security, and connectivity.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Cloud Run is a managed
compute platform
that enables you
to run containers
that are invocable via
requests or events.
Cloud Run is serverless.
It abstracts away all
infrastructure management
so you can focus on
what matters most--
building great applications.
Cloud Run, along with other
Google Cloud serverless
services, does not
run within a VPC.
Cloud Run is a regional
service, meaning services
are deployed to a single region
but replicated across zones
for high availability.
Let's dig into the
connectivity patterns.
For the connectivity
patterns, we're
going to focus on
ingress and egress.
We'll start with ingress.
By default, when you
deploy to Cloud Run,
you're given a URL that could
be routed on the internet.
The URL will always
be resolvable
on the public internet.
However, by default,
services refuse all requests
unless IAM is configured
for the service.
Ingress configuration and
authentication parameters
can be set to change
access patterns.
We'll dig more
into these settings
when we talk about security.
The next ingress pattern is
through a global external HTTPS
load balancer.
Cloud Run can be configured
as a backend service
to a load balancer through a
serverless Network Endpoint
Group, or NEG for short.
Additionally, with
this option, you
have the ability to configure
a custom domain for your Cloud
Run service.
Cloud Run services can
be accessed privately
from your VPC through the
use of Private Google Access
or Private Service Connect.
When PGA or PSC is used,
rather than clients
needing an external IP
address or using a NAT
gateway to egress
to the internet,
clients can route privately
to the Cloud Run service using
either a Google-provided
VIP for PGA
or a chosen RFC 1918 endpoint
for PSC directly from your VPC.
Private Google Access or
Private Service Connect
can also be configured so that
clients on-prem can connect
privately over a
hybrid connection
to access a Cloud Run service.
Finally, there are
a few scenarios
that can occur when another
Google Cloud service needs
to send requests to Cloud Run.
Requests from Eventarc,
Pub/Sub, and workflows
in the same project or VPC
Service Control perimeter
are recognized as internal and
can access Cloud Run directly
if the ingress is
set to internal.
Requests from another Cloud
Run service, App Engine,
and Cloud Functions in the same
project or VPC Service Controls
perimeter are recognized
as internal only
with the use of a serverless
VPC access connector,
which we'll talk
more about later.
Requests from other Google Cloud
Services not mentioned cannot
use the internal ingress setting
and must use service-specific
authentication.
However, Google
Cloud is continuing
to update the list
of services that
are recognized as internal.
Now let's move on
to egress patterns.
By default, the
Cloud Run service
connects to external
endpoints on the internet
using a dynamic IP
address pool, meaning
Cloud Run can egress
directly from the application
if the destination is on the
internet or public connectivity
is desired.
But what if the destination
is within the VPC
and requires private
connectivity?
This is where you can use
a serverless VPC access
connector.
Requests originating
from Cloud Run
can connect to
sources in the VPC
using a serverless
VPC access connector.
And the source of
the requests would
appear as if they are
originating from the connector.
Configuring a serverless
VPC access connector
for a standard VPC
is a simple process
of defining the access
connector for a VPC
and choosing the subnet in
which the connector will run.
There are two different
configuration options
for a serverless VPC access
connector for a shared VPC.
You can either set up connectors
in each service project
that has Cloud Run
resources that need access
to your network, or you can
set up shared connectors
in the host project.
There are advantages
to each method,
and you can check out
the docs linked below
for more information.
The last egress pattern is
through a static outbound IP.
As stated before,
Cloud Run services
connect to endpoints on the
internet using a dynamic IP
address pool.
But what happens if you
need a single static IP
address in the event you need
to connect to a database or API
using an IP
address-based firewall?
With the use of the previously
described serverless VPC access
connector, you can
route outbound calls
through the VPC,
which can then make
use of a Cloud NAT configured
with a static address to egress
through the VPC with a
predefined single IP address.
Now that we've discussed
routing patterns,
let's talk about a few ways
to secure Cloud Run services.
Make sure to properly configure
your ingress and authentication
settings.
Ingress has the settings
to allow all, allow
internal and load balancer, and
allow internal traffic only.
As for authentication,
you can choose
to allow unauthenticated
invocations for public APIs
or websites or to require
authentication for which users
are managed through Cloud IAM.
Additionally, if you are
using an external HTTPS load
balancer, you can configure
identity aware proxy, which
as of the date of
publication, is
in preview as an
authentication service
as well as Cloud Armor as
a web application firewall.
So let's summarize the three
most important takeaways
from today.
Cloud Run is serverless and
does not run within a VPC.
Make sure you understand fully
the ingress and egress patterns
of your service to know if you
need to set up a serverless VPC
access connector to connect
to applications and services
running within the VPC.
Set the appropriate
ingress control
and authentication settings
for the Cloud Run service.
Thanks for watching,
and look out
for another video on the
concepts of networking
for Google Cloud's
managed services.